ryan reynolds chose saint patrick's day
oh god
this is gonna be bad ryan reynolds chose
st patrick's day
uh in the eve of zack snyder's uh cut a
justice league
being released to sit down
drink gin and watch his
movie from 2011 green lantern tweeted
uh starting green lantern now first time
ever too later to ask for a snyder cut
of this effort um i only ever read my
parts
on the script so this is genuinely
exciting for me to watch
once he got to the flashback sequence he
wrote oh boy tragic childhood flashback
sequence killing a beloved parent
designed to instill a level of depth and
hard-fought empathy for our hero disney
perfected this move
he also pointed out hey blake that blake
lively is in this movie
would later become his real life life
uh ryan also took some photos of his
screen with one screenshot with his head
hanging
out in front of blake writing this was
not bad foreshadowing for my life as a
dad and
another screenshot saying trying to spot
the cgi
yeah and he did throw a compliment to
another co-star writing angela bassett
is stunning
period then tweeting do you have any
idea how weird it is to act while being
attacked by invisible space energy
i took another crack at the visual
effects saying they spent six hours
each day turning peter sarsgaard's head
into an over-inflated beach ball
but the green lantern suit is a onesie
made of old frogger pixels
but in conclusion he wrote maybe it's
the aviation gin talking but green
lantern was nothing to fear
hundreds of incredible crew and cast
members did amazing work while it's not
perfect
at any tragedy tragedy next time i won't
wait a decade to watch
so here's some footage of ryan watching
and here is
welcome to our
this planet has been our home for
countless millennia
it was created for us by the guardians
and that says this is the best threat
ever to read last night and he says uh
ryan is so sexy in that suit yeah ross
what do you think of him like
self-deprecating
finally watching greenland
i i i for me i was hoping that the
perfect ending to all those video clips
would have him getting copyright slammed
on social media
and having to pull down the entire thing
because somebody claimed ownership over
green lantern um
yeah i'm not surprised i know a lot of
people were really taken aback by his
claim that he had never seen the movie
um but i've talked to so many people
in ryan reynolds position where they've
never seen anything that they've done
because to them that's just not part of
the process
and it's not something that they it's
not something that they enjoy
um i'm gonna be honest i've never seen
green lantern
um i have no desire to see green lantern
but from what i hear from ryan reynolds
it ain't all that bad
and you know and it's so funny the fact
that this wasn't streaming so
people couldn't watch with him it's it's
not available this movie was a flop and
and he's brought the energy back to this
film and
just every he's so good i mean he the
whole point of was this
is that he on st patrick's day he was
promoting his gin aviation gin and this
is a brilliant way to do it
where everyone was interacting with him
on twitter and uh it's smart i mean he's
just so
good at promoting his products and just
it was brilliantly done so
you know what i'm going to be watching
the movie i got to find it now i don't
know where i can find it but
right i'm going to have to watch it with
the kids joyce says
you watch the movie at least 10 times
when you go to the premiere no most of
the time they walk into the theater and
walk right back out they go to the back
door and they'll actually sit there
and watch the movie klutz says i liked
it i was waiting for the second one
uh tia says hey not everyone comes out
of a movie with a wife and three kids
sounds like a happy ending to me that's
a nice way to look at it i don't know if
i ever saw green lantern either if i did
i don't remember anything about it which
is not a good thing
it is is the ring real then is that
like yeah yeah yeah
yeah so it's real it's not a cgi or i
don't think there's any
it didn't look like there's any jewels
on that thing it just looks like a piece
of uh
plastic but i mean yeah this is why
reynolds so
it's fun to see him do it like yeah i
loved it it was great
it is